pour maxime et la personne qui soit au
maximum s'il vous plaît qui est la
personne
venez venez monsieur venait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quel bonheur
ici les déguisements comment ils ont mis
de temps kerry pour te pour te suis
arrivé à 18h30
mais frérot mais ça vient normalement tu
pas avec quoi font savoir que tout le
monde avait reconnu tirer mon chapeau je
mettais sur le connais c'est sûr tu as
toi celui-là ah oui
non mon chéri d'amour est on est potes
on y voit une question il a pris un coup
de pelle
[Applaudissements]
d'irak dans cette attaque est une
question c'est est-ce que tu es la cause
de mon départ
voilà la question que je voulais te
poser maxime gagné toi toi de répondre
mais oui mais moi non c'est je pense que
non mais tu souhaites j'ai peut-être ton
avis non c'est vous c'est que je suis
arrivé dans mon post en milliers d'e
mails autres sur la tête de ma mère
le budget de la prochaine rentrée sur le
ministère de la repose des choses qui
arrivent et en 2017 mais pas du tout
plan de carrière évidemment me tiens
bien une fois temps en temps une fois dû
voir je fais une fois l'émission s'est
bien passé et puis la semaine après la
semaine d'après et l'accentuation j'ai
mon premier cachet aux boules de la 11e
fois il venait gratuite mois ensuite
après tu as dessus tu es tu as dit très
souvent que c'était un choix délibéré
absolut à part donc non il ya des gens
qui font les comparaisons mais comme
comparaison n'est pas raison on est
largement différent sus par les médias
autour de cette fable pour vous quelles
suites les coups c'est bon et bien sur
arte merci à mon tir y exploite les cons
qui veut te voir tu nous regardes pas
dit la vérité a évidemment je regarde
c'est vrai sur scène en kanaky qu'un
acquittement
évidemment jean midam en est à vue
qu'ils savaient pas que tu venais et il
a dit que nick drake tenue manqué de
talent oui oui je sais j'ai écouté à
écouter ça tenait à remercier d'ailleurs
sur twitter a battu voix et lui il est
sur twitter il est là maintenant je suis
très heureux vraiment de te voir tu dois
piquer d'ailleurs je je je bosse ça
serait comme tu veux tu veux rester un
petit peu je me suis même très bon
[Applaudissements]
avec chéri chéri ça me fait plaisir se
voir les gens rigolaient c'est énorme
parce que tout le monde allait me
thierry may